[Music]  when people think of Giza they think of  the pyramids and maybe the Great Sphinx  and they should they're amazing  monuments but digging deeper reveals  hundreds of tombs with decorated wall  scenes and texts that inform us about  every aspect of life in ancient Egypt  in this course we'll meet the Pharaohs  and high officials of the pyramid age  then follow in the footsteps of the  great 20th century expeditions will  investigate Egyptian art decode some  hieroglyphs and see how cutting-edge and  digital tools like 3d modeling are  reshaping the discipline of archaeology  join us on this online expedition to  uncover the history and significance of  Giza  I'm Peter der Manuelian the Philip J  king professor of Egyptology and  director of the Harvard Semitic museum  and this is Pyramids of Giza ancient  Egyptian art and archaeology  [Music]  you